[Music]
black is someone who is struggling with
his identity he is a sexual man who is
kind of combating that and the best way
she knows how as putting on this facade
this you know physical armor I did not
write the character to look like
Travolta trivanti
is actually came in to read for the
character of Kevin then which ended up
being played by Andre Holland and I
remember
javante was reading and my producer add
a little mask it was already passing me
a note and it said not Kevin black
javante his presence was so strong it
made more sense to me to make this
character black be more like the person
from Vontae something I loved about him
in the role is how he defies stereotype
and expectation from the moment that you
see him and you think oh I know what
this character is and the man inside is
nothing like the man outside he's slowly
backing away from who he is to the point
that he creates his whole different
version of himself between who he feels
like he could become you know and it who
he truly is but I think about the third
story Black has decided I'm just gonna
completely shut that part off but the
way my life has been sometimes you just
meet someone you know or someone from
your past returns
[Music]
you